hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Faith chapter three if
you haven't seen Faith chapter one and
two I will not be playing them in this
which is the Unholy Trinity you have to
go back and watch them in the past or in
the future whenever that is
but it's time
Marathon mode no
it's time for chapter three if you did
see Faith one and two and you don't
remember what this is It's a journey
that is going to take some really dark
turns
notes new game
hmm all right show needles for Dinah
I don't know Turbo convero
confirmo
well anyway
can
confirm
[Music]
September 21st 1986.
I remember when I played the first one
it really surprised me because of like
what the game actually was because it
was very easy to judge it by its looks I
don't need to tell you that this
assignment is something yes sir based on
what I saw during my previous visits we
could be in for a very long night
is this your first exorcism
[Music]
yes sir
[Music]
are you afraid
you they actually are talking
that's father tree that's Papa to you
give me a word of advice
follow my instructions with exactness
don't trust what you may see or hear oh
got that weird ass animation Style
you can call me daddy Ward or you cannot
Lexi and I'll give it up to your
judgment of whether to keep that in or
not you can you can bleep me out feel
free to bleep me out
oh this is the same house from one of
the earlier games though
hi do you mind
never mind
she's in the back I had to tie her up
Don't Be Afraid Mr Martin the Lord's
servants are here
yeah okay whatever you say
thanks for the vote of confidence dude
I really appreciate it why do you have a
mannequin down here
why would you ever have a mannequin down
here
[Music]
oh boy Ah that's not good
either that's blood or that's someone
holding a doll am I alone here
uh father uh papa big papa big big all
right anyway I'm going in I don't trust
what I see and or here
uh hey papa
uh Papa all right
hmm
oh good great I love mannequins I love
them so much
oh hi this is uncomfortable
how you doing good great oh
don't make any sudden movements now Amy
Amy
respite add me demonium
oh
hey what's up
you can call me fall
three days until the profane Sabbath oh
God is it that time again I almost
forgot wow
John we don't have much time the profane
Sabbath is almost upon us if they find
Nate and Jason they will perform a
ritual on them to call forth a demon of
unspeakable power the name of the demon
is malfoth I am in the process of
discovering their whereabouts I will
contact you again soon we must not let
them do to the boys what they did to Amy
father Garcia well
I don't exactly know what happened to
Amy
but uh I'm assuming that all is going to
be fine what's up with this
apparently I'm not going in there and I
don't see why anyone should question
that definitely not me
John I can't find Nate or Jason Martin
in the State foster care system it's
possible that after what happened last
year they went to live with relatives I
will try to find out what I can
meanwhile go investigate the clinic
where Amy worked we must find the place
where they intend to summon malfas and
disrupt their plans via con dios father
Garcia all right
by a con Dios
I
I don't speak Spanish
hey what's this
have you forgotten already things are
never quite as they seem if you can't
discern the truth from lies you could
try remembering what you know to be true
press Escape or the start button to
review your notes
I'm sorry are we already in this have I
already forgotten something important do
I need it what do I need to know how do
I need to know it
what exactly are you telling me why am I
in the basement why would I be down here
hey laundry out demons from my clothing
big on stains ah I see
I go down
ah I go out ah leave yes
I'm ready
well so far so good so far so now so
many D is that a penis
is that a penis all right anyway
I almost died that truck almost killed
me but it doesn't matter what you think
I have rights oh God I'm gonna get
smooshed will I get smooshed if I'm just
standing right here
hey you wanna see a cool trick
[Music]
[Laughter]
I
uh
I'm morticed whip takes you let's see if
I cannot do that let's see if I can do
marginally better than that
there we go
out demon get out get out
It's gotta be some other way I don't
even know where I am something about
club and I need to figure out where Amy
worked because I need to figure out
where the demon gave him oh beefal Fest
but
I don't know what that means calling all
metal fans bielsefest ah rocks the hell
out of Hartford okay the door to after
burst great unless there's a clue in
here Friday night You misspelled night
tended to featuring appearances uh trust
no course over is the basement to
yeah I don't know there's probably a
clue in there but I can review my notes
stupid fool
what
oh you you feel watched you you feel
watched you feel watched you're being
watched right now
I don't know I'm fine what the frick is
this
facts around Erickson hi Rhonda just a
couple reminders about last week's visit
please keep your desk tidy our patients
need to feel at ease with their health
care experience remember our sales
points clean quick courteous do not
return any calls from the Department of
Health before notifying me first or
leaving a message with Tiffany one more
thing keep Jeffrey out of sight remember
Gary loves you who the hell is Gary oh
who the hair is Jeffrey who's Miss
Martin hmm
I don't know what any of that meant hey
um
God man this priest real smart Ain't
Nothing Gets By this guy oh okay well
that's
lovely that is ah
something
this is just me or something up
that's fine that's fine nope okay yeah
baby baby name baby ain't doing good the
baby baby the longer I look at it the
more that baby ain't doing good
all right good great well this place is
terrible
I am uncomfortable
there's football down south I don't know
what that means why is that chair right
there I don't like that chair I don't
like this chair good oh demon chair
demon chair all right
is that a Kroger
wow
did they now good job I can use this to
take care of the boards over the door
so I'm guessing I'm guessing
holy God
oh no oh
[Music]
well
that was not pleasant oh I can move
I need to hide how do I hide what do you
mean I need to hide I'm on a freaking
Gurney give me your blow
[Laughter]
oh God
I am dead
yeah I see that maybe there's something
I can do to put a blanket on me is the
only thing I could guess
oh I'm dead again oh
man this is uh the opposite of good
it'll you'll never find me you'll never
find me ah he found me or right let's
think about it okay I gotta I gotta
think critically about this what if I
just don't move
what if I just don't move what if I just
don't move oh I'm dead
oh I'm a corpse
[Music]
more of this all right maybe it's
simpler than I think it is maybe that's
it maybe I just literally put myself out
of view is that what I do is that
because I'm I'm hidden I can't see me
how could it see me I can't see me
I'm right under your nose you stupid
fool
idiot
oh it really was that easy
look I don't know what you are but you
missed your chance when you didn't kill
me the first time you got me that's your
fault uh do I make a run for it now is
that do I run I feel like I should go
for it I feel like I'm supposed to be
going I feel like this is me
oh God is this when I do I go for it oh
God
[Laughter]
I made it apparently good God I can't go
upstairs though so how am I gonna do
that
I think I can make it over to the left
whoa that ain't good yeah boy yeah I
know what you mean
[Music]
oh boy no I can't oh well that's a
problem
oh it's just me I'm just in the corpses
boom I'm dead
oh so dead I'm so dead it's working
uh just another
over here oh
I'm dead
Marg
fascinating I don't think I can go
upstairs with the oh hey
uh hi
oh yo he's crazy story
okay good you know honestly I'd prefer
that thank you very much
you okay yep what are we going am I
leading why why am I leading this
uh why don't we go up here hey you know
there's something crazy up this way
oh
interesting uh officer I swear there was
a demon or something
something horrible
all right Officer just to keep your head
on us will
goodbye
how did you get in here how did how did
you want it you I uh how did you get in
here
I don't know man you shoot it
uh
thank you thank you okay don't worry I'm
gonna get it now
third time's the charm
uh officer be careful officer be careful
officer be careful
officer
over there now whoa careful officer
[Music]
uh-huh
okay good job pal
all right good good
oh oh okay I see what's happening
well that's good we survived oh
I uh well oh
uh oh
[Music]
officer are you okay
oh
all right
in the balls uh what is what is in the
is that my logo
on the left there
is that a really low M with them no way
no way no way oh no it's a loop okay
well I don't know what that's about and
apparently I I can't pick up that gun
so uh it's all for nothing
great all right I guess I'm done here
uh goodbye everybody
man what a nice
good day's work I feel proud of myself
and what I've done so I can go home with
my head held very high
or something like that
oh good something else is going on in
there
no it just lives in my nightmares oh
never mind
oh right right
I'm getting the book
series oh take her tears Ali
abduru
right uh oh uh the book somehow went
over here
objuro taste Serpent's dis Gators
I keep dropping this book Butterfingers
over here X scarcizo taper Doom vivam
oh sorry
Christie even tourism
[Music]
get out of here go be gone parent demons
come here you
hey did you move these mannequins hey
did you guys move these mannequins did
you guys move I probably shouldn't leave
the other father there what are you you
don't know how to get out of your own
basement really
well you gotta stay up here now
yeah stay here what is this
say what
uh
uh okay well do you mean like that's not
your daughter as in you don't know who
that is in the basement because that's a
completely different problem that we
have here
um
but if it is just a different situation
where it's like oh I don't know my
daughter ah it's a demon uh taking over
like that's fine but um
the other possibility I think we
definitely need to
understand
[Music]
uh did you write this in your own blood
or whatever or something happening I'm
alive
hello
man these funky dreams two days until
the profane Sabbath all right
[Music]
so uh what's up profane Sabbath
[Music]
huh I still don't know why
but I get you oh letters
John for now this is the only way I can
contact you I think they're watching me
I need to come over as soon as you can I
need you to come over as soon as you can
the situation has gotten much worse my
address is Thank you Lisa P.S if for
some reason I don't answer the door get
the spirit key from my friend Tiffany
all right Tippy I got the hiccups John
there's an apartment building in New
Haven where they may have an attempting
to summon mouth fast I'm not able to go
there myself it's up to you to stop
their rituals vaya con dios father
Garcia
John I don't know if you're getting my
letters or not but I hope you'll be here
soon I really need your help they're in
the apartment I see them all the time
now I can hear them in the darkness I
haven't slept in days when you get here
just come straight to my place Tiffany
can't be trusted don't talk to my
neighbors either they won't let me leave
I'm getting a lot of mixed signals here
Lisa
whoever you are very strange let me just
pop down to the basement see if there's
anything amazing there maybe I had
clones and finally close the vinyl have
been purified no no down there
[Music]
all right where am I going now
I mean obviously I'm going to Lisa's
apartment maybe but I have a funny
feeling that Lisa might not be there
when I arrive either due to some
horribly corrupt ritual
or because
she's lost it
hello
among the damn bed
how among the Damned am I how damned am
I
how bad is this going to be
hello Mr Ward I'm sorry to have worried
you I'm perfectly fine I have not been
feeling like myself lately however I am
much better now please do not trouble
yourself with coming to visit I have
decided to take an extended vacation in
the country so you will not find me at
home
I should check my other notes from Lisa
okay for now this is the only way I can
contact you ah so this I mean clearly
obviously this is definitely not Lisa
because Lisa was always
addressed me as John
so that should be an indication oh I
need to know what level
Pearson so is Lisa o5a
okay o5a so I need to get to the fifth
floor I'm guessing the elevator probably
doesn't work
foreign
[Music]
elevator animation
I just got a weird flashback to add dead
of night I gotta check to see if there's
another game from them coming out soon
I really like that game a little
frustrating at times but it was cool if
you like playing games the first floor
is a great place to start over however
to play the game you must know the rules
beware if you have a susceptible Soul
you might get pulled in I'm playing a
game right now
okay five A's what I'm looking for o5 a
I'm not gonna be sueded I gotta go
straight to o5a hello that probably is
not a good sign
well I was told to come straight here oh
demon in demon in nominee Pottery okay
so Tiffany is not to be trusted
apparently well Tiffany do you have a
key this may not be Tiffany
Tiffany
Bethany
well this is a problem Tiffany's
probably on another floor and I didn't
look ugh
okay
I gotta find Tiffany T Boone oh eight a
could be a t Robinson okay so there's a
t Robinson
o3b and o8a those are my two options
hmm it's hope oh that's probably not
good
that's probably definitely not good I'm
just gonna take this I'm a priest
don't worry it's all okay hey Tiffany
how you doing out demon all right I
can't go in there
all right I'm just gonna go then oh boy
I love this show oh okay I'm gonna go
what's that sound
supposed to be lightning what is it
the war of War happening War were
declared
I'm just gonna guess this is the right
key
[Music]
I really hope those sounds aren't coming
from this apartment I'm about to go into
oh good ah
walked right over your salt oh Damon
oh demon
oh
god it worked
know that would happen oh demon what is
that oh wait I still don't know what
that is what am I looking at
I still don't know what this is supposed
to be knife over some kind of mass I
don't know
if you wish to break the seal of a loo
your answer lies in the blood-stained
knife and the face hiding in the deep
dark but only those who have ascended to
the highest point can descend at lowest
depths remember Gary loves you who's
Gary who's Gary
the highest Heights do you mean go to
the 10th floor
is that what you mean
I mean this doesn't seem even like a
clue this is kind of knife over a mask
well I knew that but
I guess I have to go to the highest
floor I'm assuming this is the clue that
it wants me go to the highest point so
we can go to the lowest maybe I go to
the basement eventually I think there
might be actually be a basement because
if I went off to the mail room and I
went down there was there was a path
that went left
and seemed to go down
if I go to the right I might be able to
get to a roof maybe hello goodbye
ah well seems like my intuition was
correct
oh never mind I'm dumb
oh
m
sacrifice what you cling to this yeah
yeah
oh I don't know if I want to go into M
the Markiplier room oh hey what's this
basement dumb waiter how to use pull up
the handle open hatch Place item or
being to be sacrificed inside the
container pull down the handle and close
lines push button please make sure your
sacrifice does not jostle around inside
the container do not open hatch once
dumb waiter has reached the basement I
do not have enough earplugs and I am
tired of people losing them
please wait for the green light to come
on before using okay
oh interesting
give up the cross
it's so beat
uh goodbye
uh I guess I'm gonna go to the basement
now
oh candles woo
[Music]
what are you
[Music]
whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa hey I'm coming to
get you
oh
Gary lied to us when you see it run well
I don't know if I will I don't know if I
will he went this way I know he did
I know I went this way oh coward coward
cow word
oh I saw well you didn't run oh who is
this
oh
of course it's a camera
no
no way you're doing this in a nest game
oh no way
oh nowhere
oh fascinating oh I don't like it
Tiffany
Tiffany
oh boy who is that
where did I see cross why why did I see
uh
interesting
priest God
of course
oh there's a hole in the wall
oh
what do I know about it
oh God
I'm going for it
okay I'm just gonna go oh God they're
gonna be behind me aren't they oh
oh wow that was a lot of mayhem
oh wait a minute wait what was that
I don't remember being here
oh I'm here again
uh-huh
I'm just gonna go
whoa
that's very quiet
I don't know if I like this guys I don't
know I like it
oh I'm trailing blood am I bleeding I
bet is it my blood is it my blood it
might be my blood
eyes my blood
stairs
okay
oh boy
hi oh good great okay
all right
okay good good good you are cheating
okay
where what do you mean
okay so far so good
so far so okay
oh my God I should probably keep moving
oh this is terrible
it was terrible
it's terrible terrible terrible terrible
terrible
okay
so I gotta go to the basement
I can go in the elevator maybe no
no
okay down I go into the basement I made
it I went to the highest height and I go
down to the basement low
I feel real good about my decisions
I feel like this is where I'm supposed
to be oh laundry
oh good it's my crop
[Music]
all right okay
well
uh huh my beloved Gary alas the mask is
already stained with blood my blood the
ritual is complete you will not find me
on this Mortal plane for I am beyond
look for me in the Unseen World if you
dare Tiffany
Lee this whole apartment complex Tiffany
really wasn't to be trusted okay
um
different
I don't know
I'm supposed to kind of like the camera
a little bit it's pretty cool I guess so
what do I do I need to get a knife or
something was I supposed to pick up a
knife on the way sort of my journey
all right
I guess I'm confused
oh wow I was probably supposed to
oh hi
[Music]
oh hi
okay
I'm fine well that was fun
yeah out demon that's within me or in
Demon that's without me uh okay so what
do I do what do I do maybe Tiffany's
place I guess
I guess it was like in the back of
Tiffany's place there was kind of like a
sacrificial table maybe I gotta go there
and I don't know get a knife or
something
okay
oh whoa
oh whoa ah Breeze got good
oh I was right
no I yes I was
brothers and sister praise the
Unspeakable we have graced with the
presence of another great demon Aloo is
here I do not understand his motive but
he has put his seal over the bustle's
door this may be Tiffany's doing but it
may also be a test of our faith do not
cease to pray swallow your pills you may
have twice as many as normal seal
yourselves in with bricks and mortar and
if that so-called priest shows up take
him and eviscerate him over the altar
preferably still alive remember Gary
loves you
ah
[Music]
I don't really remember where I'm
supposed to go
um I'll go back up to oh right
this is uh pretty intense all right
um I might have missed something in the
basement
[Music]
2B did I go in 2B
oh yeah
hmm
brothers and sisters this must we will
be hosts to a very special visitor it is
here to help prepare the way for the
coming of the Unspeakable of course due
to its special nature it has full access
to the entire building including your
apartment's bedrooms Etc if you are
lucky enough to see it you will do well
to not approach it or speak to it find a
dark dimly lit area and try to stay out
of its way one of you will be blessed to
find it has made its home in your
dwelling do not go down into the hole it
will make no matter whose voice you hear
down there if you believe one of your
fellow brothers and sisters is inside
please notify me and we I will retrieve
their remains in a timely manner also
just a reminder that rent and utilities
are due by Friday love Gary Gary does
love me
Gary
Gary you're such a sweetheart I don't
know if this is pertinent to what I need
to do to get out of here but I'm just
exploring I guess I forgot that I like
from the previous games it was something
where you need to blast the walls with
your your Candlelight but knife
knife no
no give
to me
oh
oh
I didn't blast the ball of course I
didn't blast The Mask Tiffany's mask
every initiated follower knows that in
order to bring about the second death
one must sacrifice seven bypass seven by
passing them through the carved out of
the impure vessel's face then shall the
Unspeakable reward with the second death
such was the fate of that
already you how dare you my beloved Gary
has set his sights far too low I will
surpass her okay
go for it do your thing I'm not stopping
you all right but that is what I need
now I go in the basement I just blast
the hell out of that face
probably Tiffany's face probably and
three two one
oh gone
I should have known
all right now Lisa's door is finally
open
took me long enough
all right I'm on the way no note for
that one no no all right fine whatever I
will be back when I get there or if
something happens
what are you doing you know my secrets
you don't know [ __ ]
you know you're out ow wait a minute
that seemed marginally unfair
that oh are you kidding me
hi yeah
what
oh I gotta go back oh what the [ __ ] what
I didn't get the knife are you kidding
me what the hell is that about
oh oh oh oh oh I see oh oh God oh God oh
God oh God oh
[Music]
okay well all right it's a little bit of
a dick move that you didn't save when I
got the other things as well
um but I guess you didn't expect anyone
not to do the thing to the mask
even though I didn't know that but it's
okay and now all that [ __ ] that I just
did has now been I'm [ __ ] done it's
fine
okay it's clearly by the candles it's
doing something ah okay
[Music]
holy [ __ ] go away
are you dead are you gone am I okay all
right now we continue on with this
adventure I'll be back once I get that
stupid knife
I did it I did it I did it everybody I
did it all right I did it I did it again
okay we're back on track 5A
ah good the door is open I would have
had to kick it hello Lisa are you okay
Lisa Lisa out demon out demon out demon
demon out hey hey god
um
yeah this whole apartment's kind of
[ __ ]
[Music]
okay who are you
hey stop it stop that you just cut that
out all right okay
oh that's not Lisa oh God okay uh all
right well
wow oh my eyes mom well fight it John
I'm fighting it I'm fighting it I'm
turning I will not turn into purple guy
I will not yay
all right so I gotta watch where that
demon goes or something I don't know
[Music]
I'm trying to fight it I was there a
specific order that it was supposed to
be
am I dumb
take
this okay
oh that's what I thought
[Music]
all right I don't know is it order based
I don't know what it's based on
oh come on what am I supposed to do here
I'm trying to fight it oh God
oh
I'm so sorry
what no wait no I don't get a second I
don't get it I don't get another
no no way no way no no no no no no no
way no way no way no no no no no no no
no no no no no
[Music]
okay good good good that's what I
thought I don't know if it was about to
reset right after that but I was really
trying
hey
hey
[Music]
all right I'm gonna go for it this time
I got this whoa I got it I nailed it
got you apparently oh so you do just
kind of have to get the right one I just
I just got bad luck a thousand times
over
I guess but oh it's one of those first
two maybe something like that
yeah
a loser stop it
hey you're stuck on a statue stupid
oh God oh my God oh my God oh my God
Lisa I saved you Lisa Lisa Lisa
Lisa Lisa Lisa
oh okay you you good
[Applause]
[Music]
it might be too late
will you are you sure
am I crazy did I not see everything that
happened to you not see the salt and the
blood on the walls of you are you okay
I don't understand
since another demonic seal was broken
somewhere beyond
what do you mean what do you mean I
don't know damn what you mean do I go
home am I done what do you mean
what do you mean I don't know what it
means what demonic seal elsewhere am I
supposed to go looking for it in the
apartments I don't know I'm not going to
I'm definitely I'm done with these
apartments I'm done with them I'm go I'm
out of here I'm out I'm out I don't even
know
I don't even know if there was anything
else there but I'm done those apartments
I'm good I believe them behind me Lisa's
got it all taken care of Lisa has a
handle on the situation I am a simple
priest what it is is going to tell me
what I missed oh boy
foreign
[Music]
I don't like
it I don't like it I don't like that no
I don't no I don't like that okay
[Music]
hide and seek hello
hmm
what was it
hi
Mr and Mrs Martin
are you uh
are you there
Mr and Mrs Martin
oh
Bob's glasses oh good yeah no no no
you're dancing with me
hello hello
ah
well that's nice okay I'm gonna go
upstairs
anybody here anybody home hello
hello everybody
I don't remember anything further do you
not
do you not remember anything further
Amy are you
I don't remember anything further
uh-huh
why do I get the funny feeling someone's
gonna jump out of me all at once
why do I get that funner feeling oh hey
okay
why are there so many mannequins in here
hi
hey what's up
yes
why do we don't have to
wait
I don't know who that is
South
issues
yes
okay
Mr Martin
I mean wasn't father already dead in the
basement
oh I'll do this myself yeah take some of
this
oh God all right well you're a little
Speedy but that's uh that's no problem
for me I'm I'm real quick
one day until the profane Sabbath
all right sure whatever you say
what do you say pal whatever you say can
I go in here yet hello
I guess I'm not going in there
John I'm getting reports of children
exhibiting strange Behavior at the
daycare center on the four streets who
is giving you these reports if Nate and
Jason are there then you can bet that is
the place where they will try to summon
malfas there's no time left go to the
daycare and find out what's really going
on fear not vaya con dios all right I'm
about to I'm about to [ __ ] up a daycare
ah I'm gonna like beat the demons out of
all those kids I just gonna beat the
ever living [ __ ] out of those demons
definitely demons 100 demons
all right yeah daycare hello
are those cops gonna beat me to beating
the demons out of the whoa don't worry
guys I'm here excuse me hey what's up
what's the happening apps
uh hello
hello
don't mind me I'm a very sneaky priest
I'm going in leave it to me
oh that's a convenient hole in the
daycare
also you know I could have asked any of
them I think I learned my lesson last
time that I went into a place after a
police officer was like don't go in
there that maybe I maybe I shouldn't go
in there
a riddle priest how do you make a portal
to Hell come see me and I'll show you
Gary uh
uh the tunnels await what tunnels what
tunnels what tunnels are we talking
about oh
well at least they're learning their
letters wow oh
whoa I love The Wubs
oh good oh what
ah interesting
Gary loves us
mother Moon watch with her little ones
behind the door of sleep daughter
Charlie sizzfield an offering to the
master in the Unseen World Spirit Bird
arriveth from afar and cometh back to
roost these vessels are the unholytunity
the volun star shall guide them what
colors can you see look for the children
if you are lost okay so clearly there's
a puzzle and I bet the colors on the
this are going to guide me
red star
blue purple red okay red red blue marble
red red blue purple red in the corners
blue and purple
oh I see
[Music]
wait a minute because the star okay so
the star was red in the drawing okay
mother Moon watches her little ones
behind a door of sleep daughter chalice
is filled
Spirit Bird arriveth from afar and
cometh back to roost okay so the girls
are peripheral daughter chalice so
purple girls
mother Moon
behind a door of sleep
[Music]
oh oh there's more oh while I was doing
it okay
that is a yellow sun and uh blue rain
cloud I think it's very poor art shows a
lot of lack of integrity and really
doesn't help me solve this problem
orange moon
oh
dream
she's a good dream
Uncle Earl ah Uncle Earl might be dead
ah
purple chalice well I knew that already
our family good
oh
that looks like a orange moon to me
well that's cool
that's less cool
oh God why are there so many thanks
satin thanks satin that's great I don't
want to go in this other room I don't
know if there's anything in there that I
need to know
[Music]
okay
great Bluebird it's a bluebird it's a
bluebird okay Bluebird orange moon Blue
Bird orange moon red star and purple
chalice that's right that might be
enough wait let me go over unless it's
front door bluebird
[Music]
wait a minute
[Laughter]
I shouldn't laugh I should not laugh
ah God damn it okay well at least I know
what it was okay it was red star orange
moon Blue Bird Purple chalice and then a
blue bird
oh that was it I got it this is where it
lives what what is it hi ill
oh God okay
well that's fun
that's very fun
oh hey we're away from me guys hey hold
up there whoa what is this good all
right
if you're reading this and
congratulations you're on your way to
the experiencing the wonders of our
unspeakable future under the guidance of
Gary Gary our brother Gary our friend
Gary our normal human beings just like
you and me has a tier one acolyte you
are just beginning your journey your
unspeakable journey to eventually see
what Gary sees and prove yourself worthy
to be a vessel fit to experience the
second death reserved for only the most
worthy to find out if you're a vessel
remember to attend meetings of the
Eternal order of the second death twice
a week follow Gary's instructions
exactly and be honest with him in all
that you do do not ever ask what is
behind the door in the basement of the
clinic okay what's behind the door in
the basement of the clinic
wild ranged explodes
what's that she consumed six little
Twigs only two were left to walk as
husks go ahead priests stare into the
eyes of my mother all right
whatever you say I'll do it whatever
Gary what kind of name is Gary blah okay
I'm staring into the eyes of your mother
oh I'm winning
I blinked I'm staring again
oh
I think this is a part of the staring
goddess where I started to hallucinate
oh boy
oh
I don't like this
[Music]
well
your mother is lovely
where am I going
hello
[Music]
all right gaze upon the magnificence of
La pieda Carreta gets beautiful statue
depicts a faithful member of the order
receiving the second death and a loving
Embrace of etmatter two such statues
were commissioned thanks to the generous
patronage of the save family we invited
everyone to reverently approach the
statue whenever they are in need of rest
what
if you are reading this congratulations
you have officially been granted tier 2
status in the Eternal order of the
second death
upon Crossing into threshold from tier
one to tier two your life is inaccaloid
will change dramatically you may start a
noticing shadowy figures in the corners
of the rumor experience feelings of lost
time with all the curb objects what
ancient symbols Written in Blood will
materialize on the floor and walls of
your home animals will no longer trust
you you may admit a foul odor that will
cause you reformer loved ones to avoid
you these are just a few of the
marvelous blessings that await you in
this new stage of your life if you
remain loyal to Gary you're Journey
towards becoming a vessel for the second
death will progress to new levels of
knowledge and power remember if you
neglect your weekly meetings or do not
pay that your ties to the order your
fingers will be forcibly bent backwards
Gary loves you
honestly in the cosmic grand scheme of
things with all the satanic explosions
of death uh not that bad
yeah melt idiot
take this five seats in the north facing
west five seats in the south facing East
male giveth favor the low seats are made
high oh boy here we go okay or dog
stirth his pot full of Sinners the seat
resolve revolved
more
[Music]
I don't know okay
[Music]
oh boy all right five seats in the north
facing west five in the south facing
East so the five up top need to face
that
that way and the five in the South need
to face that way Andres South Discord I
don't know which one's andrith
or dog stirth his pot full of Sinners
the seats Revolt I don't know
what
[Music]
that's actually almost there okay bail I
don't know bail has this Bale
whoa oh my God why would you do that
oh my God
am I dead
did you not low
did you not like me doing your puzzle
uh maybe it was like man if they can't
get this in a few tries might as well
just give him some mercy
oh yeah wasn't it like way in the
beginning it was like in some kind of
farm or was that a different game I'm
thinking of
it was very similar Aesthetics of course
hmm
take that Amy
[Music]
I oh good oh great
good what
I am confused
Ah that's not good
[Music]
I look away for one moment and now oh
that's not good either
now you are ready Gary
am I ready here oh okay uh am I ready
uh
[Music]
uh I don't remember anything further
apparently I don't remember anything
further
well I'm out of here
I'm out of here give me okay
hi hey what's up
horrible
but I'm alive I'm not yes I am
time to solve this puzzle Gary you think
the little puzzle okay wow uh you are
right there
nominate battery okay
something tells me the second death
wasn't nearly as pleasurable as they had
hoped bye
unsure about that one
hello I remember you but I don't
remember this oh you had two statues
being Commissioned I remember now
filthy acolyte the substance of Gary's
influence flows through your veins
you're corrupted Beyond repair your
family and friends have forsaken you
there is no returning from the path you
have chosen only Gary can save you now
give up and fully let him into your
heart and mind if you do so he will make
you into a vessel of worthy of the
Unspeakable resisting your soul will be
lost forever welcome to tier three Gary
loves you okay Gary well oh thank you
I hate that
I don't know what that is
[Music]
oh all right I thought that would do
something
what is the walls
hello
what are you what is the walls
what is the you and what is the walls
what is that
oh
that does not answer the question of
what is the walls because that is uh
that is even more confusing than it was
before I don't know even know what I got
I don't know at all what I got
I don't know
well you want to run that by me again
what did you say to me you son of a
[ __ ] do you think you can just say
things like that and you can get away
with it you think you can survive you
think you can Razz well
okay all right it's a little ridiculous
don't do that again
you did it again
Estes
quad my testes
[Music]
quad sumos errors do
uh
oh take this
that's what you get ah
more of this that usually works
that usually works I would say oh come
on maybe I just let bygones be bygones
uh bygone
later gone
hey I made it
shockingly I survived because I'm
amazing
all right let's up here more death or
tier three acolytes
you know I I appreciate all of you
becoming tier 3
tier three acolytes of my channel means
the world
um and I think you all know who you are
and how much I appreciate you
big breach big breach all around hey
what's going on oh it's it's mirror this
better be a mirror ah what is that NAB
get it get gone no don't do the thing
you're doing don't do it
yeah well I thought I could beat it and
all right you get out of here
it's like the THX thing
foreign
this out first or something
yeah take some of this
what is that about whoa whoa whoa where
do I go
[Music]
that's what you deserve I don't know how
I did that but I did it well I got what
I came for and everyone else can shut up
because they suck you dear three scrubs
ain't nothing on my tier three acolytes
for the second death of which you all
are yearning and I know you're yearning
for it I know you're yearning for it
you're just yearning for it don't worry
I deliver where Gary falls woefully
short
hello this is bad for me that's bad for
me that's bad that's bad for me okay
don't do that for some reason I keep
thinking I need to do that but the
answer is that I oh that's a problem
please
[Music]
mortis I'll Mort your tits okay well wow
all right I'm gonna kiss your Mort just
hold on I'm going a long way around
[Music]
all right easy let's play Red Light
Green Light oh
no oh
I know I can take longer than that feel
it out
all right
[Music]
[Music]
oh God
I made it
you suck you suck
are you gonna try me oh no oh can't get
me all right what do I do about this how
about you eat each other
I know what to do about this
dude uh yeah you change if you get close
enough I see hey what's up
[Music]
you go down here
that's good that's good that's good
just like that oh [ __ ] I'm doomed I'm oh
well interesting that's weird
no I made it
I made it I made it I did make it in
fact I made it I shockingly made it
wow
I don't know how I made it but I made it
hey I'm back here what do I do again
what am I supposed to do ah save okay
good thank you for that what do I do
all right
probably this
well time to do a demonic ritual of some
sorts
yeah
yeah oh yeah
delivered two in the Malik's hands
before opening his navel
that's what I do I'm a priest apparently
I sacrifice things so that we can do all
this nonsense
diving in too deep yeah I I kind of have
that feeling that I'm going a little
further than I would need to uh in my
quest to save whoever the hell I'm
saving but at least the walls are happy
you are now tier 4 acolyte you have
descended Beyond everything that you
could possibly save you your words are
not your own your actions are not your
own your body belongs to Gary your face
itches for the warm embrace of the
ritual mask you long for the blinding
pain of the knife you truly are Gary's
chosen vessel fear not only a little
longer and you will experience the
second death adios AMA perdita Gary
loves you
kind of a destabilization thing going of
the partake of the dark
I'll partake of the dark why not
don't know what the dark is all about
but I'll partake oh
seems like the darkest partaking of me
Ah that's it this is getting dark
[Music]
yeah it's getting dark
um
I don't even remember why I'm doing all
of this I don't remember why this uh
needs to occur um I'm beginning to think
that my mission has kind of been LED
astray a bit like you know a kind of
lost sight
but what do I know I'm just a priest
not Lantern that's that's good
thing they put it all the way in the
back
oh yeah it's a good thing also that it
gives less light than uh when I didn't
have it that's good
I hate that whatever that is
uh not good hey what's up
how you doing
oh God all right well that's just cheap
that's just cheap that's just cheap take
this
purple guy what are you doing here
weird
fascinating
hmm
ah again with that that's not gonna give
me twice
not gonna give me twice I'm better than
that
better than you
hi goodbye hi goodbye
okay
okay
what is that you asked backwards
whatever you are what are you
all right
man this cross really takes care of
everything
oh good blood I'm good good good good
good great good
oh good yeah nope all right okay just a
big thing
all right great
tree
Maybe
I don't know what the
[Music]
okay
hey wait a minute hold on here wait this
seems uh oh this seems a little unfair
well all right there's a lot of you huh
we'll take some up
God yo oh you did oh you're gone
you thought you could and you didn't you
thought you would and you shouldn't you
don't know what kind of priest I am you
don't know what I'm capable of whoa
get some
I don't like the wall of bodies
not that I particularly like anything
that's happened so far
my dearest colleague Jacob thank you for
the letter I am delighted to hear of the
success you in your Venture uh in
Pennsylvania however it was not enough
to persuade me to join your cause I have
no interest in crumbling ghost towns nor
government experiments nor the gibbering
behemoths that lurk shamefully in the
darkness Between Worlds such matters are
not worthy of my expertise my methods
may be more delicate than yours but I
assure you they are given to me straight
from this Source the Antichrist will
step forth very soon the second death
will consume this world this pitiful
fleshy sphere still in its infancy yet
everlastingly too late to redeem when
the time comes I hope we may reunite as
cohorts albeit not as equals love always
Gary and PS I almost forgot to thank you
for the pet I will keep it outside my
private quarters as a guard against
intruders
what
hi
which one's Gary middle one
oh these are just
good pals just good pals here okay
what what do you mean what do you know
oh god oh wow
I don't like you I don't like you at all
I don't like that I hated that I hated
that
I hated that
also I don't know where I'm going
that was weird I don't know what that
was about
okay all right so there's a few of those
things whatever they are
lightsaber wielding things
that I need to destroy to be able to
unlock the yada yada and get out of here
apparently
uh
so I'm guessing I what I just got to do
is follow these blood trails and then
they're gonna leave me where I need to
go
easy as that
there you are
boom done
done
I did it
well all I do I gotta do is go back I
should be good right
there we go all right easy peasy I think
I thank God I hope you really want to
open this door yes yes I do hi what's
going on over here what's up guys are
you all tier fours oh [ __ ]
I've heard this one before
something about you just wait and see
her uh I love you or I've always loved
you uh it was in my nose wait wasn't
that my notes come see me and I'll show
you okay well that's not really
did I do that
did I do that whoa these things are fun
okay all right good
these tier sixes
okay good great that's good to know uh
good to know uh thank you for that also
and uh thank you for that
[Music]
yep
that's me
hi
huh
Gary
hi Gary yeah
somebody please help me
hello
[Music]
I hear God darkiplier John son of man
what Dost thou wish
oh man
I am so afraid please let me escape this
place I've kind of walked into your
willingly so I don't know and the girl
uh
I'm dear I'm down if I lead us thou to
safety
her fate shall be sealed upon thine head
I will do whatever you are you scared me
away from here I feel like I
want more swear it huh
I swear it huh
it's the profane Sabbath
okay
[Music]
[Music]
it's a nice glasses
what what will you ask about oh man uh
injection uh Gary Gary
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
uh
uh Amy
perfect
area
all this going on there
oh
I don't know how I know you're
capitalizing my there but I do and it's
annoying me okay
oh what about this yeah I'll change
something whoa God I'm oh man that hurt
well this is a problem
seems like I'm dead on guard you your
face oh yeah wait
huh you seem to be moving a lot less
fast than you were before
oh God no
ye gods
take this
I'm sorry what did you just say oh God
no
you don't bust out the old reign of
spiders on me do you that seems horrific
take this and this
don't do it ah miss me
please don't do not keep doing that it's
the worst attack I've ever experienced
stop doing rain of spiders it's just
horrific
it's really mean oh God
[Music]
pick this and one of these and one of
this don't do it don't do it oh oh God
I'm dead I'm dead
oh God
yeah oh boy
man I'm really cutting it close with
those
oh God I should have moved sooner your
spiders
well this is going well for me this time
oh
oh damn it oh damn it oh damn it I got
it you're done now nerd
oh god oh no please
you're done now nerd
that's faster I don't like that
no no no no God no
oh God no no
yeah you're too slow okay well that's
hardly fair
here John now nerd
[Laughter]
whoa
hey that's effective
that's really effective
I should get one of those instead of my
sticks
it really is
all right do you have two of those
I weirdly I'm not with you at my side
I'm not I don't think I'm ever going to
be afraid
uh okay I thought you were gonna Mouse
okay
wait what
I had a funny feeling
foreign
feeling that I missed something
um what do you what do you mean what do
you mean what do you what do you mean
well that's hardly fair
uh
oh God I do what are you kidding me
okay all right thank you if I have to go
through that again I'm gonna be real
pissed where do I go what do I do what
am I what am I doing what what am I uh
what am I War
okay oh God I do I
more this
do not talk to me do not talk to me
oh my God are you kidding me
you're [ __ ] kidding me
all right I'm doing something I think I
don't know what I'm doing but I'm doing
it uh dude can I get a defensive here oh
God
please please buddy please could you
actually hit the right target
oh God oh God
oh God okay good good very good very
good very good very good very good
Wham oh oh God
don't kill me okay I did it
I did it
They're All Dead hmm
well
[Music]
nice car father
you might not pointing that thing at me
really made a good team down there
if only we've been working together from
the Stars
probably destroyed
boys
[Music]
I told him my face will ever be as
strong as it once was
[Music]
[Music]
your teacher
okay sounds good
wow and that's a team
and that
is
faith
chapter 3.
I think
obviously there's something about this
that I have not solved 100 but I'm not
going back right now to complete it
maybe down the road at some point in the
future I will do the entirety of this
but I imagine that is going to take a
lot of doing
but that was very nice it was good it
was a little frustrating at times but
just I think that's a mechanic of what
the game is it's not necessarily a
reflective of the game as a whole it's
like the the constraints of which it's
put in right it's supposed to be like an
NES level game it's supposed to be
extremely low res and limited in that
facet and still provide an entertaining
experience besides that so it's very
cool I'm happy with that and I'm proud
to have played it so thank you everybody
so much for watching and this extra long
episode I wanted to do it all in one I
didn't expect it to take as long as it
did however I'm glad that I played it
and if you want to see Faith chapter one
and two those are also linked in the
description below and if you have an
idea of what is going on deeper in this
what is happening
[Music]
after creditings
ending one new purpose Ah that's right
there were multiple endings even in the
other chapters which is strange because
in doing there's a continuation between
the chapters but that's how games are so
if you want to play this for yourself
link to this game is also in the
description thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you
in the next video bye-bye